vamos a comparar los números 0.7 y 0.09
hay muchas formas de hacer esto pero la
forma en la que yo lo voy a hacer es
comenzar revisando cada uno de los
dígitos comenzando por el dígito que
está más hacia la izquierda comenzamos
en el lugar de las unidades y vamos a
comparar lo que hay en el lugar de las
unidades en ambos números si comparamos
esos dos números pares ambos son iguales
ambos tienen cero unidades lo que no nos
dice mucho ahora veamos el siguiente
lugar a la derecha el lugar de las
décimas este número tiene siete décimas
mientras que este otro no tiene ninguna
décima ya con esto solamente sabemos que
este es el número más grande y ponemos
nuestro símbolo de desigualdad así con
la abertura hacia el número más grande y
la punta hacia el número más pequeño así
que 0.7 es mayor que es 0.09 y quizá
ustedes se vean tentados a decirme oye
espera si nos vamos un lugar más a la
derecha nos vamos a encontrar que aquí
hay un 99 centésimas
aquí no tenemos ninguna centésima
incluso podríamos escribir un 0 acá para
indicar que no hay ninguna centésima de
este lado pero estas 9 centésimas
realmente no importan recuerden que
incluso aunque tuviéramos aquí 10
centésimas sería lo mismo que una décima
por lo que no importa que este 9 sea
mayor que este 7 lo que importa es la
posición en donde están aquí aunque
aumentemos una centésima más tendríamos
sólo una décima y aquí tenemos siete
décimas hagamos otro ejercicio
digamos que queremos comparar 0.29 y lo
quiero comparar con 0.31 quizás esto
ustedes puedan verlo un poco más directo
depende de cómo lo conceptualicen
podemos decir que aquí tenemos 29
centésimas y aquí hay 31 centésimas por
lo que tengo más centésimas del lado
derecho así que mi desigualdad se abre
hacia el número más grande y tenemos que
0.29 es menor que es 0.31 y podemos
decir que 29 centésimas es menor que 31
centésimas otra forma de hacer esto es
observar las posiciones de valor si nos
fijamos en el lugar de las unidades
ambos números tienen cero unidades pero
si nos fijamos en el lugar de las
décimas vemos que aquí hay dos décimas
mientras que aquí hay tres décimas y ya
no tengo que seguir viendo los demás
números a la derecha puedo comparar
estas dos décimas con estas tres décimas
y como tres décimas es más grande pues
puedo decir que 29 centésimas es menor
que 31 centésimas
hagamos otro problema más vamos a
comparar a 0.6 con 0.06 cuál de estos
números es el más grande pues hacemos lo
mismo que hemos venido haciendo nos
fijamos en el lugar de las unidades
ambos tienen cero unidades no nos dice
mucho ahora vemos el lugar de las
décimas
aquí hay seis décimas y aquí no hay
décimas cero décimas así que este número
es más grande tiene más décimas que el
otro y no importa cuál tenga más
centésimas recordemos que las centésimas
son mucho más pequeñas que las décimas
son una décima parte de las décimas
aquí hay cero décimas aquí hay seis
décimas por lo que este número es mayor
0.6 es mayor que 0.06 y de hecho es diez
veces mayor pero hablaremos de esto en
otro vídeo